everyone this is kevin from the chest
website com pleased to announce we just
launched some very powerful software on
the website software that typically you
may spin between anywhere from fifty to
two hundred dollars and even the problem
with that is you installed on your
computer and you don't have it on any of
your other devices even your other
computers this is great because it's
actually on the test website calm so
anywhere you have access to the chess
website calm you're going to have access
to this software now there's two parts
of the software the part we're about to
go over right now is completely free so
if you haven't already checked out go
the website check it out you don't have
to sign up for anything you can use it
right away and it solves one of the the
problems that so many people email me
and ask me about and that is giving
analysis on a specific board state a lot
of people see me a screenshot and say
hey Kevin who's winning in this position
and what's my best move how should I
continue in this position and that's
exactly what the software does again you
can use it anytime you want to so I
think you guys are really going to join
i'm going to show you kind of what it
looks like so you're familiar we're
going to go ahead and just set up the
board state so all you have to do is
click a piece and then click where you
want it to go we're going to do pretty
basic here well i'll just do is a simple
opening so y'all can kind of see what it
looks like we'll do the do the italian
game here and we'll just move the pieces
a little bit and there's analysis
parameters you can again change how
in-depth you want to get with your
analysis we're going to keep it on 20
moves as far as how the the computer is
going to go in one second so not very
long again the computer is a lot smarter
than humans but you know in one second
you can't do too much but again you're
still going to get a pretty solid
analysis we're going to go and click
analysis and it gives you a strength
evaluation if you're not too familiar
strength evaluation score plus means
that why does ahead minus means that
black is ahead a whole point that is
meaning why it is up a pawn in material
now it doesn't always have to be
material advantage sometimes if you you
know if you're about to checkmate you're
going to have a very high point even if
you don't have more material but again
it's just kind of a gauge as far as who
is winning in the game because again
it's not always who has the most
material it's who has the most material
actually in the battle but this with
your case both sides are pretty equal
zero point zero
would be complete equality and both
sides are pretty equal they have kind of
the same setup it is White's move so
sure slight advantage 0.1 sounds about
right it also has a recommended line for
white again this is what a lot of people
ask how should white continue in
whatever position it is or how black
should continue in a position it gives
you recommended line this has four lines
or four moves and so if you click on
recommended line it you can actually
move through those lines now the
strength evaluation is not going to
change as you go through this but you
could always you know actually do the
strength evaluation of this right here
if you wanted to even go deeper from
this position we can always come back we
can change the strength of our the time
limit so if we come back to the board
we'll go ahead and click will do five
seconds here and we'll click back on the
the board up here we'll keep it the same
and click analyze and again before we
did one second it gave us four moves and
we click on analyze this time same
strength evaluation so again still
pretty much equality but it gives you a
different line so it's again it's got a
little more in-depth we've gone a few
more seconds and we've now got five
moves you can actually click on this and
go through the five moves so again you
know pretty pretty cool stuff so again
that is kind of what it looks like if
you set it up from you know the very
beginning of the boards if you want to
go through the first ten moves from each
side and see what it looks like you can
also set it up if you want to clear the
board so will clear the board if you
want to add pieces from the left hand
side just click one of the pieces click
it on to the screen where you want to
add it so we'll go ahead and add a
couple rooks I'll go ahead and add a
pond over here for Whiteside but let's
go ahead and change White's move to
black to move so it's blacks to move and
we'll click analyze again we'll keep it
on the five seconds just to see
hopefully it's going to tell us to take
this rook here on a one and it does so
again dot dot dot means it's now blacks
move so strength evaluation negative 5.4
that means blackheads definitely ahead
even though he's you know same material
right now he's about to take material so
definitely an advantage and as it goes
on while this strength evaluation won't
change black strength evaluation will
technically still be going up because
he'll have you know a much better
position in the game so again we can
kind of go through it and so we can say
you know it takes that pond and then it
kind of guides you through again this is
all contingent on how the computers
running through it but going through all
these different moves and then
eventually you know black would take
material and then go on to checkmate his
opponent so again this is extremely
extremely powerful stuff that I think
you guys are really going to joy and
again this is completely free so if you
haven't checked it out I definitely
retic recommend going to the chess
website calm and checking out the chess
analysis now for members we actually
have an additional section that I think
is going to be really really helpful for
everyone that's looking to take their
game to the next level one of the best
ways to get better at chess is to
analyze your own games so many people
will play a game the loose they'll play
another game they'll lose and they're
not really learning and trying to figure
out where they went wrong and this is a
great way to take one of your games and
have an entire analysis on the entire
game so what it looks like is there's
now two options for members at the top
so you have to be logged in custom board
and PGN custom board is again setting up
a position that's free for everyone PG
and you can actually paste one of your
own games into the move history over
here so I'm just going to go ahead and
delete this over here and I'm going to
paste mpg and if you're not too familiar
with PG and it's a format of all your
moves it kind of looks like this so you
know pretty basic this I basically just
copied one of the the more famous games
out there but you could do it with just
the moves orders you know one dot and
then whatever depending on where you're
actually playing they usually generate a
PG in file for you but all you have to
do is just put that in there and hit
analyze now I'm going to go ahead and do
one second for the time limit for each
move you can definitely change this if
you want to get more in depth but I'm
going to go ahead and hit analyze and
right away it already gives you the
strength evaluation and recommended line
and you can go through the entire game
and this is very powerful because you
know in this particular case the
strength evaluation is not going to
change two months because we have two
Grand Master's that are actually playing
against each other but in your own games
you're going to see some very very large
swings in the strength evaluation so you
can actually go
through and actually see where you're
making mistakes and you can actually
click on a specific position you know
we'll click right here on H takes on g6
and actually see okay who's winning in
this position what's the recommended
line where did I go it says recommended
line is night to c5 they actually chose
to go nice to see you bye perfect so you
know these people actually decided to do
exactly what the computer said but in
your own games you can look at and say
oh wow white swimming and then the next
move wow black is winning by a lot that
was maybe a bad move and you can
actually go through and again do the
recommended line and actually see what
the computer recommends in that position
so very very powerful you can also again
change your parameter so you can change
time limit you can change the search
step although I think 20 moves is
actually pretty solid you can always
change that the time limit for each move
that it goes through if you want a
deeper analysis also if you want you
know extended line at the bottom so
again this is going to be super super
powerful for those members of the chess
website that actually want to analyze
their own chess games again there's
unlimited use so I you know again use
this as much as you guys want to that's
what it's there for I think this is
going to be a huge addition to the
website again there's tons of free
content and you have this for members as
well so everyone should be happy
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
kind of explaining about some of the
cool stuff I have some other great stuff
to announce coming out in the websites
in the near future so stay tuned and
I'll see you all in the next video
thanks for watching